a comienzos de este año nosotros vimos
que la discusión acerca el cambio
climático se recrudecía un poco producto
de los incendios que afectaron a la zona
centro-sur de nuestro país entonces yo
por lo menos era parte de hartas
discusiones y bueno claramente esto
parece no ser tan natural que parece ser
espontáneo y la duda es bueno nos
estamos calentando en chile poco a poco
la temperatura ha ido aumentando cada
vez más o simplemente este año fue algo
completamente particular y que va a
volver a pasar pero quizás en mucho
tiempo más
entonces lo interesante que uno puede
hacer hoy en día gracias a que la
dirección meteorológica de chile ha
trabajado muchísimo en levantar los
datos históricos que uno puede hacer
este análisis y de hecho
yo les pedí este análisis en el curso
que yo enseño en la escuela ingeniería
que es el curso de base de datos donde
los alumnos aprenden a manejar base a 2
ya tratar de levantar información de
este tipo y este es uno de los
resultados que los alumnos entregaron
esto es una actividad
y calcula la temperatura media en enero
en la cuenca del maule entre el año 2007
y 2017 estos con datos de la dirección
meteorológica de chile ustedes pueden
ver qué bueno claramente por lo menos en
lo que la cuenca el maule se refiere la
temperatura no ha estado en aumento
progresivamente de hecho había una
tendencia a la baja hasta aquí el año
pasado se pegó un un repunte
bastante considerable entonces me
gustaría poder mostrarles más datos pero
lamentablemente no todos los alumnos
hicieron la actividad así que vamos a
ver que conformar con con la cuenca del
maule esperemos que en el futuro quizás
puedan hacer hacer más actividades como
esta y la razón por la que por la que
los alumnos no hicieron la actividad es
porque esta actividad era bastante
engorrosa de realizar si bien los datos
estaban lo que nosotros teníamos que
hacer era meternos al explorador
climático de bueno el centro del clima
de la residencia y la dirección
ideológica de chile donde nosotros
podíamos descargar los datos históricos
de sensores de las cuencas de chile como
planillas excel planilla excel que
estaban sucia a veces planilla excel que
no sabíamos cómo interpretar otras veces
planillas excel que tenían datos que
nosotros teníamos que integrar entonces
al lograr el gráfico y este análisis de
la cuenca del maule un análisis bastante
simple nos tomaba algo así como dos
clases o tres clases pues es un proceso
bastante engorroso
y lo que lo que les quiero venir a decir
hoy día es que nosotros ya tenemos la
tecnología para poder levantar este
proceso estamos un poco entrando en una
nueva revolución de la información donde
la tecnología nos promete ser capaces de
realizar estos análisis como el que
hicimos de la cuenca del maule en
muchísimo menos tiempo y con muchísima
más variedad entonces si el día de hoy
nosotros queremos realizar otro análisis
parecido por ejemplo no nos interesa la
temperatura media nos interesa quizás la
variabilidad o la cantidad de horas
donde la temperatura supera un cierto
rango nosotros tenemos que volver a
abrir estas planillas quizás otras
planillas integrales hacer otro proceso
de una semana entonces la revolución que
se viene que es lo que yo le prometo que
la revolución viene vamos a ser capaces
de hacer este tipo cosas en 10 minutos
entonces déjenme contarle un poco una
perspectiva histórica para que entiendan
a qué me refiero con una revolución no
sé cuántos de ustedes acá conocen lo que
es lo que es esto
espero que todos lo conozcan esto es una
es una foto de un pedacito de la
enciclopedia británica la enciclopedia
británica es una de la enciclopedia más
famosa hoy en día todo este trabajo en
siglo que ya está está un poco obsoleto
pero antes y por mucho tiempo la
historia si nosotros queríamos buscar
información de algo teníamos que
meternos a esta enciclopedia entonces si
nosotros queríamos buscar información de
algún país en latinoamérica por ejemplo
si debemos buscar información de panamá
digamos a la pea la pegada buscábamos
panamá y ahí estaba toda la información
que queremos buscar información de algún
animal
tenemos que encontrar ese animal en la
enciclopedia y ahí no nos entrega toda
la información
por supuesto estará bastante engorrosa
si yo quería hacer una comparación entre
todos los países de latinoamérica tenía
que uno por uno ir a buscar a la
enciclopedia los países de latinoamérica
tienen que sacar una fotocopia a la
parte de los países latinoamérica y con
eso tenía un tomo bastante más reducido
pero sin embargo grande y finalmente
hacia la comparación el otro problema es
que la descubierta ni cantera mide como
más de un metro probablemente un metro y
medio y debe pesar bastantes kilos
entonces si yo quería hacer un trabajo
con otra persona algunos de nosotros
tenía que traer la enciclopedia entera
para que pudiéramos trabajar era un poco
engorroso entonces la segunda revolución
que es algo que todos vivimos aparece
con el civil está una imagen de la
enciclopedia encarta 95 era una de las
primeras enciclopedias digitales o al
menos la más famosa en ese entonces
y funciona igual que una enciclopedia
solo que ahora tenemos portabilidad
ahora si yo me quiero juntar con una
persona hacer un análisis ya no tengo
que meter todo la enciclopedia
britannica en un camión sino que me
basta simplemente con llevar un bueno
antes eran cuatro civil ahora puede ser
un civil entonces avanzamos un poco y
podemos hacer más y la última revolución
llega con internet ser tontos e internet
nos trae hartas cosas primero nos
entrega páginas web yo ya ni siquiera
tenía que tener un civil para poder
acceder a la enciclopedia segundo nos
entrega a buscadores en google que era
una especie de abrir esta enciclopedia a
todo lo que fuera página web a todo lo
que estuviera en la web y finalmente lo
que estoy mostrando acá es la imagen de
wikipedia que es esta enciclopedia en en
internet y que no está editada por una
cierta cantidad de editores como el
enciclopedia britannica o carta sino que
cada
cada persona puede participar de
wikipedia puede entregar más
conocimiento entonces lo que yo podría
haber hecho por ejemplo era podría y yo
podría haber subido el gráfico de lado
la persona que hizo esta actividad en mi
curso por haber subido este gráfico y
haberlo subido a wikipedia con eso ya
pasaría a integrar el conocimiento
colectivo que todos tenemos el problema
es que todavía estamos limitados a eso a
wikipedia no va a tener otra cosa quien
no es lo que ya ha sido reportado por
otra persona si yo necesito encontrar
datos para responder alguna pregunta
absolutamente nueva yo no lo voy a poder
encontrar en google porque eso tiene
tendría que estar alguna página web yo
no lo voy a poder encontrar en wikipedia
sino que yo tengo que empezar a
levantarlo lentamente
la próxima revolución se trata de tratar
a toda la web y todos los datos que
nosotros tenemos almacenado en una serie
de lugares por ejemplo los datos
meteorológicos pero también otros datos
de diversa índole tratar todo eso como
si fuera un gran gran gran repositorio
de datos integrados
y eso se llama semantic web en inglés o
web semántica en español y nosotros en
el centro de investigación de la web
semántica estamos trabajando en lograr
de alguna manera diseñar y aplicar esta
tecnología para lograr que esto suceda
entonces si esto si esto funciona sé yo
lo que podría ser ahora mismo cuando
quisiera por ejemplo ver la variabilidad
de la temperatura en los últimos de años
no en la cuenca del maule sino que por
ejemplo en antofagasta o en la cuenca
loja yo lo podría hacer inmediatamente y
si hubiera si tuviera los datos y la
tecnología de la web semántica ahora
siempre estoy limitado a en movimiento
planillas a bajar cosas lo puedo hacer
pero me voy a demorar bastante más
entonces lo que nosotros hemos logrado
nosotros como centro investigación y
también el mundo entero que estaba hay
mucha gente participando en esta
tecnología y ya tenemos los cimientos
necesarios para hacer que ésta esto se
vuelva una realidad tenemos los
cimientos necesarios para hacer que toda
la información que está en el mundo
pueda actuar como una gran base de datos
lo que necesitamos es que las entidades
empiecen a abrir sus datos y empiecen a
colaborar entregando entre
en chile hemos avanzado bastante esta es
la página del portal de datos abiertos
del gobierno hay más de 3000
repositorios y se van aumentando cada
vez más pero esto no es suficiente para
nosotros
los datos de gobierno generalmente se
encuentran en planillas excel en
documentos pdf en cierto gráfico a veces
por ley de transparencia que no tiene
que ir una oficina llevaron un usb drive
para que para que ellos te carguen los
datos porque son demasiado pesados para
subirlo a internet y todo eso toma
muchísimo tiempo integrar todo eso es
muy difícil entonces lo el movimiento de
datos abiertos desde que participa el
gobierno ahora y es parte de lo que
ocurre con la dirección metereológica
nos garantiza transparencia nos
garantiza acceso libre a los datos pero
yo les digo que nosotros podemos hacer
más
nosotros podemos masificar este acceso
no a los mejores de alumnos oa los más
trabajadores del curso de base de datos
sino que a cualquiera que le interese a
cualquiera que le interese tener esta
tecnología nosotros podemos no
limitarnos a tener datos históricos sino
que tenemos podemos lograr datos y datos
actualizados entonces yo quisiera por
ejemplo saber qué temperatura hay en
puntarenas hoy día con los datos de los
sensores si esto estuviese ya instalado
yo lo podría hacer
les voy a dar le puede dar un ejemplo de
lo que nosotros podemos hacer con esta
con esta tecnología
y ese ejemplo tiene que ver con adrián
que está ahí en mi alumno de doctorado y
el año pasado adrián viajó a tokio para
presentar en una conferencia y se
encontró con un día libre que es lunes
entonces adrián quería ir a ver un museo
tokio tiene más de 1000 museos no todos
tienen señalética en inglés
y los días lunes para los que saben hay
muchos museos que están cerrados
entonces adriano tenía idea de cuáles
museos podía ir tenían solamente un día
quería saber qué museo están abiertos
qué museos estaban cerrados quería saber
que eran bueno quería saber qué museos
eran malos quería saber qué información
había del museo y lo que se propuso
hacer es integrar
es integrar datos de wikipedia datos de
twitter datos de yale que ya tienen la
tecnología que yo necesito para la web
semántica ya abren la base de datos por
completo entonces lo que agregan se
propuso hacer es ir bueno yo le voy a
preguntar a wikipedia la lista de todos
los museos esto que os voy a pedir de
twitter que me de los últimos tweets de
los museos en tokio voy a pedirle a yelp
que es un servicio que entrega rating
que me ve los rating de los museos en
tokio que me indique si es que están
abiertos o no están abiertos del lunes o
sea la consulta entrega algo como esto
lo de la derecha son tweets no los vamos
a leer personas son 140 caracteres estos
son los tres museos que tienen un mejor
rating en enjel hay dos que están
cerrados el de al medio está abierto es
el zamora de misión
y twitter aporta un poco de información
de contexto dice bueno hay una
residencia samurai donde uno puede ver
como la gente vivía en los tiempos de al
parecer este museo termino haciendo
bastante bueno si ustedes van a todo si
alguna vez es recomendable e interesante
y está abierto el lunes también
entonces
yo por supuesto que bueno adrián podría
haber recopilado esta información
simplemente usando google el seguridad
mitiga wikipedia a la lista de museos de
tokio
para cada museo podría haberse metido a
la página web podría haber visto si es
que está abierto o no está abierto se
podría emitir a twitter podría ir
buscado los últimos tweets pero esa
búsqueda hubiese terminado siendo
demasiado engorrosa y finalmente hubiese
perdido el lunes entero tratando de
encontrar que hemos hecho podría ir esta
consulta con la tecnología que nosotros
tenemos y gracias a que wikipedia
twitter yelp abren los datos de la
manera que nosotros necesitamos con que
conversa con la web semántica toma algo
así como 10 segundos entonces podemos
podemos ahorrarnos muchísimo tiempo y
nos entrega datos actualizados y nos
entrega algo que podría llegar a ser a
ser masivo entonces está un poco el
avance que nosotros tenemos que ir
haciendo hoy en día nosotros nos
encontramos en la mitad
ya tenemos un gran movimiento de datos
abiertos en el gobierno que hay que ir
levantando dado el llamado que les
quiero hacer ustedes que por favor no
nos quedemos acá esto sí nos garantiza
transparencia nos garantiza mucho acceso
pero nosotros podemos ir más allá y aquí
chile nosotros hemos desarrollado
también parte de esta tecnología
si nosotros aparte de tener datos
abiertos nosotros abrimos la base de
datos es lo que se conoce técnicamente
con la uned point de base de datos es
una abertura directa a los datos
piensen que es el equivalente a yo tiene
en mis datos que yo puedo consultar en
mi propio computador bueno eso ha
llevado a la web si es que los servicios
y el gobierno y los gestores de datos
nos empiezan a entregar eso esa
tecnología nosotros ya vamos a ser
capaces de hacer estos milagros vamos a
ser capaces de integrar tecnologías de
completamente distintas
distintas fuentes de distinta índole y
vamos a hacer en 10 segundos en un
minuto cosas que si no tomarían semanas
tomarían día y tomaría muchísimas horas
hombre entonces por favor necesito su
ayuda el día de mañana o el día de hoy
si es que ustedes tienen se encuentran
con con gestores de datos no solamente
necesitamos datos abiertos eso está bien
necesitamos transparencia pero también
necesitamos masificación necesitamos
datos actualizado necesitamos que
confíen en la nueva revolución de la web
semántica y que traten de abrir los
datos abiertos si ustedes buscan
información de cómo hacer esto va a
estar en google disponible lo único que
necesitamos es un poco de buena
disposición y de que confíen en nosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]